thank you to our sponsors surf shark the
guys have come through yet again they
love this channel they love the audience
and there's a reason they keep coming
back is because people are interested in
getting a VPN Brian what is a VPN I hear
you say virtual private Network correct
virtual private networks are very
important in the modern internet they
keep you anonymous online so all those
nasty people out there can't keep
tracking you and what you're doing
because your business should be private
whether it is just surfing around online
or whether you've got something you want
to sort of keep to yourself either way
surfshark giving you incredibly well
cost effective service at the same time
as keeping the quality there not only
that but it's not just on your phone or
on your laptop or ever it's on all the
devices that you own so if you get surf
shark and is a great offer for this Surf
Shop then you can put it on your phone
you've got your iPad it can go any on
any of the devices that one size fits
all right genuinely one size does fit
all these offer well the offer is 83 off
three months for free and they've got a
30-day money-back guarantee so if you
don't like it for 30 days in those first
30 days you've got it you can go you
know what not for me not feeling that is
unlikely because they are such a great
company they offer such a great service
so we believe in them and that's why you
will they really are fantastic so thanks
a lot to Surf shark for sponsoring this
podcast we really appreciate it there
are plenty of other users out there
online but if you get the service you
can find out what makes surfshark the
VPN for you
okay okay
just looking through um I opened it up
to uh this slot online
said what do you want us to talk about
so at the top at the top of the part
what sort of things are they saying I
mean one of the replies just first first
reply first reply the whole thing [__]
porn so what do you what do you think of
Niche pornography such as
[__] Pawn I mean everyone's gone I'm
not sure you can say [__] anymore I
think you have to say uh people of
smaller I'm courting him here right okay
yeah so this is not what I would have
called it now what would you have called
it I don't really feel comfortable just
describing it in any way shape or form
what do you mean well it just sounds
smaller people still have sex just on
the other end of the spectrum smaller
adults yeah just to be clear I mean I'm
hungover so this is probably not the
best time to do um to do a podcast book
it's the Queen's death should we start
on that at least get that get that out
there because then we'll do them I've
wore the t-shirt for just for her that
is the album cover for was that Sex
Pistols yep yeah of course he uh the
lead singer of The Sex Pistols was
notoriously shut down by uh a good
friend of the queen uh who shot him down
again uh Jimmy Savile yeah because he
was the one was the one who went we all
know about your seedy little stuff that
you're doing Jimmy and then he never got
another
um gig apart from the butter ads but the
conspiracy guy the the opening line uh
to the song that sort of made him the
most famous God saved the Queen the
fascist regime yeah I thought it was I
am an antichrist I am an anarchist
that was a really good song to know how
to want bird and know how to get it I
wanna destroy and then he says possum
pie I can't remember the rest of it yeah
I wanna be
um
in the city yeah that was the best bet
pretty sure my Dad loved them when he
was in that no [__] [__] Brian your
dad looks exactly like the kind of guy
who still listens to those guys and goes
bloody good stuff this but that's got
like a Mohican at this point you know
he's he's in his 50s you I don't know he
can you know you're in a mohawk at one
point yeah but like yeah but I was 20.
wait do you mean like a like not not
quite pointed up but it's like slick
back but it's like yeah yeah yeah
looking like chocolate dolls
um so so the Queen's sadly passed
obviously we're devastated
a sad day my favorite my favorite
message can I repeat the message you
sent me yeah yeah absolutely yeah yeah
Lauren me immediately I said to Lawrence
look we need to have a little chill
while this happens because people won't
be able to handle the way we like we'll
get all the people crying [__] in the
morning I have a bit of respect
um right but Lawrence messaged me going
this is almost as sad as when she killed
Diana
which was just like and we just then
sent each other a message after message
after message saying the things that we
can't tweet out because we know that
people uh will use that to try and
cancel US ah England's rules
she's been dead a week now we can see
what we want although this will come out
I think the day before her funeral that
is good timing right um so what what my
favorite bit was is this is lozen sent
me uh the iTunes linked to uh Elton John
Candle in the Wind and then and and just
say press play and let it all out
because it seems to me here lived your
life they
was for the woman who very mysteriously
was killed uh at the height of her
popularity when she was
um challenging the royal family
coincidence and harboring the body of a
small Muslim fetus inside
laughs
that's what they said that's what they
said at the time though didn't they yeah
that's what they said she was with a
very rich
um man called Dodie al-fayed who also
was tragically killed in the car crash
that is a Dodie and when you look back
at that whole thing you know she does
the interview then you know the the the
The Brood mayor as she was called
basically a a
beautiful white girl Posh a bloodline
was then picked hand selected even
distantly related to the royal family
right that's what they said I mean
that's you know I mean at that level of
aristocracy of course like it probably
is that way I mean let there's there's a
good reason why
certain members of the royal family were
let's just say swept under the carpet
because I mean that's definitely a very
kind way of putting what the royal
family did to those people but okay yeah
yeah the pretty horrific stuff the way
that the royal family hid that whether
it was a royal family of the Royal
Institute I mean what a what a certain
things
um and uh
basically Diana was killed in the most
mysterious of circumstances I have ever
ever read up on like it was so bizarre
so much of that is it screams murder it
just does he was killed by a pepperoni
pizza wasn't she sorry Paparazzi sorry I
mean literally
by the way if she'd ate a bad pizza and
died it would have been probably more
believable right than the official story
do you know what I mean it's it's
so yeah um so from that moment on it
sort of makes you realize that these
people still are living in an era where
outwardly they have to act like they're
moving with the times yada yada but in
reality it's it's Game of Thrones
basically like this is the type of but
the queen so um there was this touching
moment on one of the crane trip I've
watched a few of the queen tributes just
because I'm interested in the history of
it right and the way they portray it
the queen did bow ahead when Diana's uh
car went by did you not can you believe
that this is the thing right as a lot of
people were turning on the queen at that
moment because of
the way things had gone in terms of
Diana and her relationship and the royal
Royal Family's treatment of Diana and
which I
I've seen with Harry and Megan the sway
that the royal family to this day still
has over the tabloids is is unbelievably
powerful can I just ask you one question
you know this podcast is sponsored I
don't care right okay you know you think
we start the podcast I don't care okay
and the point is is that the swear that
the royal family still have over the
tableaus now we see even now when when
we're supposed to have a press that or
harder to control than ever because of
the internet and yeah we see in the way
Megan was demonized and Kate was uh you
know made some Angel and and looking
back at it it was clear as day that they
were trying their best to take Diana
down on a public level but Diana played
the game better than they did and she
had to go she did really well like she
was a [__] other than anyone else on
um you know tomb run that tomb run or
whatever it was you know she was really
good at that as well and she did win the
hearts of the people well that was the
point is that's why she had to go and
but but the queen on the funeral of
Diana would step forward and bow her
head as a mark of respect but or but
that was literally some Godfather [__]
that is literally the moment where you
know like you're you're making out like
you're friends with your enemy I mean
it's smart and the fact that so many
people believe that it blows my mind how
and
and the fact that we even have a royal
family blows my mind oh no Brian come on
now there's a time and a place for this
and we all know that question is sorry
it's a tourism it's tourism no it's not
the numbers the numbers are there if you
want to sorry what what was up we found
out the numbers of no not true and we've
also found out that they've never
released the numbers since we found out
the last numbers weren't true yeah
because we get those numbers again you
might need to run the numbers again
don't need to run no numbers again how
much money do they take out of our taxes
versus how much they bring in for
tourism unfortunately tourism money
turns out was a lot of rubbish back to
the chosen by God stuff I think
um so yeah yeah isn't it yeah it's
pretty tricky
the idea we we live in a country where
we have a royal family who are chosen by
God that that is literally what this is
all stemming from I kind of wanted to
it's a moment it is it's mental you know
when you watch like Game of Thrones or
Russia Today and you go and there's
something big going on in Russia and all
the people are just sort of going yeah
we best just bow our heads and not do
anything to upset the apple cart that's
what this is like like there was a guy
you know the genius though the royal
family is
they have gotten it into people's heads
the the beauty of what they've done here
is
they now have no responsibility for the
state of the country at all they're not
blamed for anything they're not held
accountable for anything they live in
their massive [__] mansions and their
big old sit on their big golden Thrones
and meanwhile they they allow someone
else to take the fall and they've got
the lightning rod in front of them who
was constantly blamed for everything
wrong with The Concept love Boris
Johnson but of course he's perfect and
these guys take the full take the fall
and all they have to do is shake the
hand you keep taking all the money you
keep spending all the money and no one
ever questions anything because it's
they've always been there it's always
been like they have always been there
it's it's mental law and but I mean the
Queen's been around
I've seen Graham soon as and I mean look
Graham uh is an old man and I get that
for him and there's a lot of old people
who have a certain affection because of
the indoctrination that they've been
subjected to from the day they were born
their parents have believed and in a
time of war in first world war for
example second world war fighting for
Queen and Country King and Country it
gave people
um a sense of Pride it gave people a
sense of ownership of you will not take
down my this is my place to focus
where where it came in handy to a
certain extent to get people motivated
but we are so far it's a lot like
religion it's all of this is a form of
control and it's time that people wake
the [__] up sorry are you saying that a
revolution I just didn't get rid of them
I don't know what it requires Revolution
Brian you'd have to we would have to
March
or I'm totally wrong and we should all
be dropping off more marmalade
sandwiches they actually said drop don't
drop off any more marmalade sandwiches
can you explain that people who haven't
seen this clip of of the country so
state that we're in in the UK right so
the queen did a clip with Paddington and
I think Paddington and the queen are
sort of quite interlinked anyway because
people sort of think well you know
little lots of Paddington Paddington
Bear all right the little teddy bear
Paddington they I think we should call
him Paddington the Immigrant bear
and the queen in Paddington the
Immigrant bear are quite close in this
little clip weirdly he has an English
accent despite growing up in Panama
where does he grow up in where's he from
why are you asking Robin because why are
you why are you asking our Indian
cameraman why a foreign bear would not
have a foreign
clue about Paddington the bear the only
other person in the room for me to find
out anything from What Peru that's the
one and it turns out Robin was handy in
there right yeah so yeah
um and those two they had they did this
little clip and people loved it because
the queen was sitting opposite
Paddington what ultimately they did was
they sat the queen at the table and then
superimposed Paddington afterwards so
the queen was really just sitting in an
empty table but people had this idea
that the queen and Paddington uh are
friends and so they've been dropping off
marmalade sandwiches because I think the
queen made a comment about marmalade
sandwiches at the time nothing more
useless by the way to a monarch than
food they've got as much as they could
ever wish for I mean I just hope the
homeless um this is what pissed me off
all right is there people in this
country who don't like the homeless or
don't like poor people or don't like or
talk about oh well you know food banks
and all that they when it comes to Queen
we drop all of that [__] and we go no
drop off the marmalade sandwiches over
there mate that's all [__] good the
woman on the gold thrawn is no longer
able to eat might need a snack she might
need a snack we're not going to put it
in our tomb like some sort of Egyptian
idea you know when they used to go I'll
take it with you to the next life you
[__] genius just a shitload of
marmalade time we're just chucked up
inside of a [__] coffin but you know
you know if we were in a country where
for instance say there was someone who
was possibly a pedophile parading near
the Queen's coffin or at least best he's
a sex offender all right parading near
the Queen's coffin right and that's by
the way no one ever thought we'd have to
say the phrase at best he's a sex
offender yeah yeah if you saw a man
parading next to a coffin and someone
went sort of that was a saxophone no
it's not R Kelly we will go on to it
that guy's a sex offender and everyone
goes oi not the time or place mate
I've never seen anyone who's even have a
bit of respect had a bit of respect for
that sex offender the what well it was
never proven right it was never proven
because we never went to court because
he paid them off with the Queen's money
that we pay her and not only that what a
woman she was such a good woman
everybody honestly do you know what Grim
sooner is called though like the best
Britain ever that's not true it's not
true it's not true he said the best
Britain ever and the best woman ever or
something like that I was the best woman
ever I was literally watching Graham and
you know you got you got emotional
sometimes and he was he was and I was
just like what a life you've had cream
the fact that you are deep deep it's
just mad it's just mad okay but for a
second try and entertain with me the
idea that other people that the other
perspectives why would people why is
this important to some people do you
know why is the queen to Graeme souness
to a certain generation is it because is
traditional but it to me it was also
they grew up with no internet there
wasn't really much TV there was very
little radio so one of them they
couldn't they couldn't Google Illuminati
they couldn't figure it out what was
going on this entire [__] time yeah
whereas Our Generation I'd like to think
outside of the ones who
you know still [__] like this
[__] yeah I've worked out that we're
under control if you thought we were a
free country you clearly weren't paying
attention during corvid you [__]
idiot right but the queen didn't have
anything to do with covert though did
she David uh sorry sorry Brian
the point is is well the queen certainly
beat corvid did the queen get covered
well exactly I like the idea by the way
that ultimately the man who caused this
was Boris Johnson who refused to wear a
mask and then shut the Queen's hand on
that day I'll never I'll never forget
that
ah
this woman sat on a gold throwing man in
in a country where Gold's very hygienic
we've we've literally allowed her to
take so much money out of this economy
she's one of the biggest landowners in
the world why really why because she has
Royal Blood and we we literally allow
this to happen while this country is
struggling like [__] that's what I
struggle with or I I get I understand
can you at least acknowledge with me his
as a as a point in history this figure
and this person dying is a is a historic
moment because in in like historic terms
this is historically it should be the
last one right it should be the last one
the the the all of the the homes and
everything else should be sold off to to
and donate the money to the needy of the
UK get rid of it we now go into a
regular government [__] all this Royal
[__] yes the president's fight [__] all
this Royal [__] you do not have the
right to rule this country any longer
because we all realize the idea that you
have Royal Blood is a big pile of [__]
so but outside of the Royal Blood Punch
and Judy show is over now we're adults
now we've woken up aside from Grand
Sooners and a few others we've walked in
the [__] up and there's a very long time
it's time to go no seriously and and I
couldn't be waiting for it that's all he
gets there is no I don't know if Claude
and her going to the same place I think
Scott's going to the good bit yeah
exactly she's
maybe the queen will haunt Buckingham
Palace for a little while that will be a
good tourism piece
we've seen the queen or at least the box
of the queen over the last couple of
days then saw the queen
when they came to Buckingham Palace a
lot of people when they say tourism they
act like the queen was outside of
Buckingham Palace taking selfies for a
five or a pop you know I would have done
if I was Buckingham Palace though I
would have done you know I would home
alone it
I would have put uh I would have put
like a you know the the cut out of the
queen on a little train track and they
would have gone she's in that room they
turned the light on midday there's the
queen there's a little thing and then
you know that woman is in the shower and
he's dancing he turns him around that's
what they do yeah
exactly that's what they do with the
queen
exactly I'd give it a count of three to
get your low down dirty [__] is out of
here but they do that as the tourists
are walking round Buckingham Palace and
they have little things like you walk in
on the queen like doing a trousers out
but she's getting off the toilet like
and just little
do you think the queen wiped our own ass
oh dude I think it's weird do you think
she had a servant do that if she didn't
I want to hear the story from the person
who will ultimately tell the story like
this
a moment I must recall was the queen was
completely naked on the toilet it was
special to me because I remember seeing
her droopy breasts
and she said
I've got diarrhea
and in that moment I thought I've shared
something there with the queen that no
one ever else will have yeah specials
what was special we both laughed have
you heard the the shatter guts out
I'll be [__] have you heard how many I
like accounts from people who had a
special moment with her there were
hundreds of just so nothing and yet to
them because they were with the queen
they are like obsessed by it right uh
Theresa May has one Raven told me about
this I mean is he passed on the story I
I thought it was a crate I think it's
not even a story it's the beginning of a
story that you then go and
she went to this picnic she the Theresa
May then says everyone had to muck in as
if the queen doesn't have to like people
following her all the time and everyone
set up the picnic themselves Theresa May
has to do the cheese plate the cheese
plate goes down on the cipher oh Theresa
may drop some cheese
shits she's so silly it's clumsy Teresa
and she so she goes oh five second rule
and she bends over picks up the cheese
but she has a decision to make do I
place the Queen's cheese back on the
plate or not I just dropped it in some
poison in them that is awesome in that
moment she places it back on the plate
only to look to her left
suddenly the bloody Queen sitting on a
bench watching her isn't it but they
share a little knowing look either that
or the Queen's
um cataracts are kicked in but either
way
either way it was a moment where Teresa
got acknowledged by the queen I love the
idea by the way the queen can't see more
than like five feet we share the moment
if there's one thing that you realize
when you watch
um the crown for example right right a
documentary The Crone obviously is is a
you know dramatized version of events
that of the things that they know about
the royal family but the point is is
even a dramatized version of the Queen's
life still is incredibly [__] boring
this woman did nothing she has done not
all of this all the great she did for
the country are you [__] kidding me
she went to are you kidding me she
basically had tea and [__] scones
every [__] day for the last [__]
70 [__] years okay and what would she
do she didn't even she did nothing who's
she did oh she went to a country and and
and you know showed her face every now
and then what holiday shut the [__] up
who's gonna go to the countries that
resent us ultimately and have a tea with
the people that still don't like us and
go well this was lovely I'll be giving
everything back soon
and then 25 years later they come back
and they go we'll be giving everything
back soon but not this time and then
again they're back on the [__] flight
they never they never get them like in
the place where they go okay give the
jewels back now and they go next time
thanks for the tea and they're off
that's what happens every time
fulfill this role [__] mental we
won't miss her that we that at this
point right look I'm I'm almost
accepting right like I get why we've
done it the traditional way up until now
nobody even likes Charles nobody likes
him he's also coming inside from Graham
soon and I caught you make a great king
really
uh you know the funny thing is
Grandma soon s you know we've all he's
had his knockers
this is what pushes me over the edge
with graham Sooners and I go 90 more
gram I don't need don't need to hear any
more from you thank you I don't think
that we need any more of that but if
anything weirdly a lot of people in
England are going sort of respect that
guy now yeah I didn't really like him
before but I kind of like him now yeah
it's all weird but I don't like him
is it's sad it is sad what is sad no the
whole thing's sad just recently an old
lady who had such a comfortable life and
and saw all the best Healthcare the best
of everything her entire life
I died how old was she 986 yeah she
lived into a late night either a good or
a couple of good euros and and her
husband both of them had very long
comfortable luxurious Lifestyles never
had to lift a finger for themselves
their entire [__] life absolutely I'm
not being horrible here like I'm not I'm
not saying like I'm glad she's dead or
whatever I'm just calling calling it out
for what it is which is a little old
lady died after a lovely life Fair Play
I'm Not glad she's dead necessarily I'm
just necessarily yeah I'm indifferent I
don't care I do not care do you know the
same way the queen didn't give a [__]
about me and my life I feel the same
about hers it works both ways I'm sure
we both feel the same about each other
I'm pretty sure in fact one thing I
would say is I actually think the queen
gave and I think this is a tribute to
her less of a [__] about you than you
gave about absolutely absolutely
absolutely and that's what that's the
kind of woman she was well the
difference between me and her is I
funded her lifestyle in some small way
did she ever sponsor the kickoff not one
did she [__] did she [__] Balmoral
needed a new roof that year we had to go
short and no one got to cover the
Chelsea game when you when you watch the
crown it's another thing that pops out
is these [__] the [__] lifestyle
they live is outrageous her and all that
[__] corgis honestly who's gonna
inherit the corgis they're saying don't
shut up you [__] [__] another piece
of information I found out is that the
queen wasn't thrilled that the corgis
would outlive her for long so they'll
just shoot them in the head now will
they I don't know if they want them put
down but I don't think she wants them to
live a long life without her because
stop feeding them now then separation do
you know out of me come on a vegetarian
diet that'll sort it okay Charles
doesn't seem like
the most likable chap
from the short clips I've seen of him
have you seen the one of him doing the
ink on the table again when he goes in
the crown in the Crone right have you
seen the pen have you seen the pen thing
no okay so the pen thing he's got a
fountain pen and they have to go is it
like the signing of something in Ireland
they have to go and sign all these
papers just to make sure that he's got
the Deeds to Ireland or something oh
I've lost the bloody Deeds to Ireland
again well not mine anymore yeah we'll
give it back next time
so
Charles hasn't been picking up for 25
years next time
it was with Wales though wasn't it like
he had to go and go to school in Wales
for a bit and that right prove that he
cared about it yeah exactly like the
queen did with that time when all those
people got killed so um he he signs yeah
exactly next time next time we'll we'll
shed some tears
um so he signed something with a
fountain pen robot and then it turns out
the fountain pen has sort of I guess
because he's got these like claws he
does have quite cumbersome what I'd call
quite comfortable they're quite
reptilian some may I say all right David
and then he so he's basically crushed
the pen to with an inch of his life I'm
surprised we don't see Charles signing
paper like this yeah like crayons and
then he goes oh bloody thing bloody
thing it's always this bloody thing and
then Camilla takes off him and goes it's
everywhere it's nowhere you can't see it
anywhere it's literally there's barely
anything so and he storms off so there's
a few things
um to talk about here uh the queen
couldn't cry
what she she never cried the royal
family seem to have a problem with
excreting liquids from their body
fall apart from Jeff apart apparently
from Andrew who's very good at seating
some some liquids from his body but
other liquids from his body harder to
get out uh so the queen was not an
empath right she was a [__] robot
let's be honest with you you only have
to do a little bit of reading up to know
that about it was she not stoic would
you I'm only putting this other argument
for was she not a woman who thought I
need to be I need to be the image of
consistency and stoicism
that's like congratulating someone for
having no personality and then going she
was stoic the reality was she didn't
have a exactly a vibrant personality
that's why Princess Diana Shone like a
[__] uh lighthouse in that [__]
royal family because she was around a
bunch of [__] robots Respect the Dead
Prince Charles
he was a [__] [__] Womble like in all
of those uh in all of those stories that
they recount in the crown like he was
horrible uh he had not an ounce of
empathy about him it wasn't about nine
years older than she yeah but I mean
that's not a big deal in in the royal
family or whatever I get it is when
she's 16. all right okay I didn't
realize that
um but the point is is um he like when
she was really struggling his his
treatment of her was shocking yeah like
do you just like come Mitch is a [__]
mother or your child like show a bit of
care you said child there you don't mean
you don't mean the word children because
you think uh Harry was uh sired to
another person within the family I don't
know how true that is I think they're
probably uh related but no one else in
the royal family with oh no there is
someone else in the royal family with
red hair it's um is it Eugenie or uh I
don't know there was rumors that he came
from another one but um
someone's met one of the Royal Family
yeah
um one of Andrew's daughters really yeah
it's not Eugenie but the other one
what's the other one called why are you
looking at rovin rovin worked for PA
Tris Beatrice Princess Beatrice well I
met her I met her at uh well you met her
in a nightclub yeah did she like a bit
of the old McKenna we were chatting for
a little while but ultimately
um we imagine you in the royal family
it'd be terrible it would be I'd just be
me going I'll take you all down
just joking
enjoy your dinner well no so we I went
to a club night like a student club
night she happens to be uh enrolled in
the same year as me I was in a small
group of friends and one of our group of
friends was in the same class as her so
in walks Beatrice
like she was she had two massive
bodyguards on either side of her and the
whole night they just followed around
and there was weirdly one guy in our
group like a super gay guy in our group
and he was like he was I mean it was he
was evidently very effeminate and
homosexual you know and uh but for some
a strange reason this man had an
obsession with the royal family so he
was like so into it so I'm I'm quite
ironic why
do you think men hate him
do you think anyone in the royal family
is gay I would bet on it but I think
that they wouldn't be able to Henry
publicly see it you know I get you
William
at that point I'm just she's like here
I'm like here we're chatting I didn't I
couldn't reach out to touch her at all I
couldn't sort of shake hands or anything
because there were two big guys either
side we exchanged some pleasantries and
you know I said you know good night cool
yeah good to see you yeah Wicked all
right great I turn back around there's
that gay guy right there and he goes
you've just met the royal family and I
was like yeah he's like that's amazing
isn't it I was like yeah really amazing
he was like isn't she beautiful and I
was like
not really it reminds me of that guy who
we watch who is obsessed with the Royals
the guy with their hats and their
Badgers and stuff he was there he's
clearly he's in the clip of him I mean
I've seen the clip of him he's a [__]
State he looks devastated absolutely
devastated the guy looks like but the
funny thing is he's devastated but at
the same time he's so devastated that he
has to document everything have you
right so should we talk about the
reaction from the public to the death
because right now as we're recording
this there's a cube of people to go and
see the Queen's coffin which probably
doesn't even have her body in if we're
being honest they're not gonna just
leave the queen lying around do you
think where the public can get near it
because there's bound to be a cycle
there that is actually yeah the real
queen in the back and they've just got
like a little coffin with a mannequin in
there I don't think it's open though
it's not open Castle
that's the point I think he's Jimmy
savile's their body in that in that and
people are paying tribute to Jimmy
savile's dead body
people are going through the room and
going second time goodbye England's rose
yeah yeah uh uh there's a queue of
people just waiting to nod to the queen
seven hours long the queue is seven
hours that is double the get a life you
[__] pricks really get your life do
you not think again historic moment
don't give a [__] a historic moment to
be able to walk through a room and not
at a box historic moment these cons
probably didn't even go to like their
own family member's funeral I do often
wonder this like they're you know the
people who do really love the royal
family tend to be the kind of people who
don't get along very well with their own
family because they sort of go they sort
of go I don't have that but bloody hell
the Queen's gone if you haven't walked
enough
to what the royal family are now after
the mysterious death of Diana the
treatment of Harry and Megan
um Prince Charles his his uh his Camilla
that was revealed where he said I want
to climb up inside you uh like a tampon
did he say that do you know he had a
tampon thing okay okay here we go we got
a it was some [__] like it was some
dirty weird him and Ryan Giggs right
very similar poetry I want to be inside
you like a piece of toast in a toaster
like
um a baguette in an oven like a charger
in an iPhone or like a really Premium
One tampon get
um
racy phone conversations recorded
between Charles and his then woman on
the side how it revealed they were very
into each other right um their
relationship in the 70s and basically um
oh she become a queen issue well yeah I
think so I don't know is that Queen
elect or something Queen what queen
consult so she consort
Queen consort Charles oh God
I'll just live inside your trousers or
something it'll be so much easier
Camilla what are you going to turn into
a pair of knickers oh you're going to
come back as a pair of knickers Charles
or God forbid a Tampax just my luck this
exchange was followed by jokes of
Charles turning into entire box of
tampons and being chucked down the
lavatory he was into some sort of
humiliation [__] huh Diana's reaction
what's the highest reaction
Diana went he used to exactly I know me
apparently she described the
conversation as sick it's so weird
because I think that's quite sweet
though isn't it I mean this branded uh
sexual banter the sad thing was is that
Camilla was like a friend of uh Diana
and actually yeah they had like a weird
exchange where she sort of discouraged
her but encouraged her on other things
Camila Camilla basically was [__]
with Diana's head early on yeah Charles
yeah
um and look at the end of the day
Affairs happened it's not the end of the
world no but it's it's the murder I've
got a problem with really just to be
clear yeah I think it's also I mean I
don't like death by pepperoni
I thought it was worse that Charles like
because the queen didn't like divorce
did she she really wasn't a divorce
woman like she was a woman who was like
everyone must remain together but then
within her era
I think like a lot of her family all
just went yep off they go and so Charles
got into this position where he was the
next guy and he was meant to be like the
one Andrew wasn't really the one
I think it sort of put me in a weird
position didn't it and he he wanted to
just be a Tampax he was he was bullied
at school and everything like no [__]
[__] look at the guy Brian yeah
yeah he was a real primed for it a weird
little [__] he wanted to be Tampax
Brian yeah this guy fantasized about
being a Tampax it's Australian thing to
come up with because most men aren't
really that Keen on [__] during the
uh period during the Shark Week you know
what I mean Shark Week is what you call
it wow okay do you I guess yeah sure I
get that Camilla I don't I mean I don't
understand I felt like imagine choosing
Camilla over Diana it he shows her lapse
of judgment I think in his life he's now
King you made that decision and now
you're in charge of all of us you [__]
exactly it's a real problem yeah I get
the point though you we could overthrow
them I think you should leave this a
million Russell the thing is I noticed I
noticed Russell's video he was a little
bit on the fence about it you know yeah
because he still wants some like I think
some people we know he knows brand deals
deals at companies and go oh but they
disrespected the queen that time and I
don't know if that that cuts off 50 of
her audience apparently we're not
allowed our own opinions about stuff it
it's perfectly acceptable to think that
it's all right by the way this is the
reasonable thing to think that it's all
right that a woman chosen by God was set
to rule over this country that's
reasonable we'll sponsor that
but what's unsponsorable is someone
going not sure about that whole woman
rolling over the whole country thing
getting everything free yeah that is
unreasonable
yeah do I sound mental when I say that
that's the problem though is there's one
thing so when the news uh the news broke
about these marmalade time were just
being left all over the [__] shop and
then going if you could just stop
leaving the marmalade sandwiches now
this there's quite enough now I thought
my God I [__] hate this country why
though do you not like this I hate this
country I really hate pleasantry
[__] morons that we have outside in
this country who who actually went to
the length to do that like
who made a marmalade sandwich yeah
because I'm just like killing there's so
much marmalade there's so much serious
issues in this country we are now in a
in basically recession that's been
caused by kovid and the lockdown
specifically not covered the lockdowns
where we decided to shut the country
down for the best part of a year and a
half or whatever and now we're paying
the price for that and we're calling it
cost of living crisis because nobody
wants to acknowledge the fact that if
they hadn't have been locked down this
probably would never have [__] been
situation so we'll call it cost of
living so no one puts two and two
together and and yet their their concern
is to make [__] marmalade sandwiches
for a [__] dead woman who can't even
eat them keep trippy cheap tribute
marmalade if you buy cheap I imagine
they'll buy expensive marmalade but you
know we'll give her the good Mark give
it the good stuff give her the bloody
good stuff yeah yeah I was saying that
with the bits in do you know what I mean
I don't know I don't really know what
happens when they rot but they're the
queen no well the queen will rot but the
sandwiches when the sandwiches go what
do you do this is that's the point why
are you leaving them in cling wrap
that's what I kind of I'm curious like
the second it rained in London was there
just a load of marmalade just draining
away from where what we what we saying
then how do we how do we cap this off in
general like historic moments sure I
understand why some people are sad she's
she's been a figurehead for a lot of
people in this type on The Simpsons stop
though it's not like it's not I get for
these people like oh they've watched her
a shitty Christmas speech every year but
she's not impacting your life in any way
shape or form she's she's not she
doesn't know you're you're existing and
it's like when any form of it's a form
of entertainment almost it's like oh the
we'll we'll have a different presenter
this year for the Christmas speech
though did you know they estimated she
met three million people in her life
well done no I mean that's like a lot of
people yeah that's not when you say met
it's like yeah
exactly yeah exactly and that's the
point is in in our life we are judged
upon in my opinion what deep impactful
connections we can make with a small
amount of people and how we can improve
their life and and and build something
the very nature of the Queen's existence
was the opposite of that it was it was
[__] it was a lot of pleasantries a
lot of small talk but no real impact
there and sitting on a gold throw and
taking all the money and while the
idiots are brainwashed into believing
that this woman is having any positive
impact on society when all she is is a
taker do you think that it goes the
other way though where in Britain and in
general
Mass psychology a lot of people want to
be ruled like this a lot of people maybe
maybe they don't feel so extreme they
want to be like you know tyrannical but
a lot of people feel that they want
something people like security people
like routine and people like their
affection towards like feeling like this
is a system and I am within that and I
get it and that's the thing I realized
during lockdowns when because I felt
outraged that we were being told and we
weren't giving a choice but when I
looked and realized how many other
people were just happy that we were
going to be safe and all of that rubbish
right and it was this is how you beat
kovid and no one was even wanting the
question it so many people didn't and
those who did were basically told that
they were Nut Cases just for having it I
ask for asking just for asking I'm not
really sure about this but then it's
like
do you want people to die you know what
I mean it's like well we're probably
going to have people dying in the long
run anyway because when the [__] [__]
it's the final we've got no [__]
money and people are gonna die of
starvation and other problems Doris
didn't do that so I do no but I whether
it was Boris or whatever the mass
psychology it just made me realize how
easily controlled this society that
we're in is and that if you have a mind
of your own you are attacked for it
immediately I got no doubt we'll get a
lot of
um here on this podcast and the great
thing about not giving a [__] is I
welcome it good good for you I welcome
it do whatever yeah you know it makes
nothing I like the queen you're welcome
much like the queen oh because I don't
give a [__] about Mass opinion either
right just like she didn't yeah because
either way just like the queen I get
paid
me and the queen is not just coming can
I ask you a question who does your
tampons Charles actually Charles
when you think of the queen and you like
to imagine her do you think of young hot
Queen you know with the boobs did the
queen have boobs she she was quite busty
younger you know really I don't really
remember
um I mean maybe I'm just thinking of the
girl on the crown
or do you think of old Queen old white
hair wrinkled
soggy tits so I think of um I think of
like early 90s Queen I think yeah she
had quite dry skin in the early 90s
which um a lot of powder yeah and that
was the fashion at the time to be like a
lot of old women were quite powdery yeah
at that point I remember a lot of my
Grandma's friends when you look at their
faces and sort of stare for a while
you'd see they were sort of there was a
like their paws were sort of almost
clogged with power yeah because makeup
wasn't as good back then now you can
clog your paws with like you know glossy
[__] yeah but back then it was more
powdery [__] yeah I wonder if the Korean
had been born later and came up in this
era should have been like an Instagram
haul yeah but that's what I wonder is I
mean but I don't think the sports them
selfies was like I'm in Africa a day
right yeah so sad in it yeah yeah see
you later next time yeah hashtag next
time from the queen yes uh we'll give
you all your [__] back next time the
queen in her crown has a diamond or a
like an expensive Stone worth 400 to 500
million pounds
it was taken from one of the colonies I
think it's either India or a very low
like a lower we did need it more than
they did yeah to be fair the queen we
needed it in order to keep it what they
smartly did was set it into the crown so
that when someone goes can we have that
back they go no we're setting the crown
in it set now so you can't see that it's
not removable
no no we use super glue yeah exactly
next time and then that's what happens I
I like to imagine the queen and she said
I'm like mid-20s so sort of just after
the World War II probably when that was
when all the sex was happening in our
life you know all the sex dugging for it
right do you think the queen
um waited do you think she kept herself
I think she was Heavy petted if I'm
being honest I think okay she was Heavy
petted and then she passed it on to the
next generation and he went you know
there was a lot of fingering uh throat
[__] going on around her
um I imagine that
um what was his name the German fella
Hitler no the other one he's Austrian
um the other one the one who Franz
beckenbach nor the the German who should
she was [__] I don't I didn't watch
the Crown Prince um Prince Philip Philip
right I think Philip was was doing a lot
of heavy petting on her right yeah he
was doing a lot of problems with racist
people he probably
probably come in our ass for a while
just before and then once they
consummated the marriage in terms of
like once he got married then it's the
[__]
the Royal butthole is ready your
highness of course of course what I
really enjoy when Prince Philip died he
was a whoremonger and what sorry a
whoremonger and what does that mean so
love the love the horse uh he was
shagging about left right oh everything
everything it got back to the queen I'm
sure it did yeah yeah when she did a
test
the Queen's got the clap what we're
gonna do what the [__] hell do we do
well it wasn't me yeah
um she's there going [__] hell I've
been [__] around but has he been
[__] around yeah it must have been
you she was very close with a guy who uh
she bred horses with how'd you know all
this stuff I watched it all from the
crown yeah not a documentary not adults
but they take everything from truth
don't they and then they maximize it so
I didn't realize by the way how many
people were broadcasters and journalists
who specialized in the queen all of
these [__] come out the [__]
woodwork when this happens they're
loving it right now some of them yeah
like this is their time this is their
WrestleMania yeah this is yeah this is
the and one WrestleMania if they're
lucky then maybe they'll get a death of
Charles and the death of the queen in
their lifetime right you know we're all
hoping like it's that's what these guys
would make a good King William Woody I
don't know just just some people say it
just feel like it'd be better than his
dad he starts annoying William to me is
the mini mentor of the royal world
does that not make sense to you does
William not remind you as like I feel
like miniminter is the reasonable you
know just personable affable one of the
family he's not the deji Harry he's not
you know
um Beatrice bit him out there probably a
bit more Niche just as like Asos brand
deals it's very mainstream was the right
little slug lovable uh the Queen's
sister right Mary was it Arnold Mary
loved the car loves the car yeah she
loved it wow yeah
no but that's what I thought of you for
because really there was a bit where she
she got with this artist photographer
type guy of course she did and when you
were saying you met beerus I was like
you could have been him you could have
been that yeah the guy just I was
wondering where the shoes I was
wondering why she sort of showed her
face at this event because also when I
left I just happened to leave at the
same time as Beatrice but I wanted to
cross the road and her body would stop
me Crossing around I went not now and I
was like [__] yeah I'm crossing the road
you [__] tell me where to go
I was a bit drunk at the time and
[__] tell me and I just wander off
down like on these dangerous side
streets
live or live yeah that was that was
probably what happened at the time um so
yeah I get it like a lot of them loved
[__] is what you're saying basically
yeah should we should we look at other
topics yeah now we put down the English
public and it's a glorious leader enough
internet internet
dating app sort of thing yeah are there
good
or bad and what else we hear in here and
I do do the dating app thing okay
there's lots of others but we can no no
I'm interested uh so talk to me about
internet dating more dating questions
yes uh really is it good or bad
um do you know what I think I think
there's
there's convenience in internet dating
which is a good thing because
people are busy these days Lawrence you
know they're making marmalade sandwiches
you know they're doing this this stuff
you can't afford to take time away from
work a lot especially I think if you're
in A build-up area like London I get why
people would
uh see the value in it because there's
that many people in London the days of
you being able to get out there and meet
people who are in your area it's
impossible in London right single local
women in your area yeah no but like I
guess when I was when I was a lot uh you
know in Newcastle there was like a
handful of places you'd meet girls and
you'd pretty much know they'd all all go
at the same place so this is how it
worked when when say you and I were a
little bit younger what would happen is
Monday Tuesday Wednesday maybe Thursday
Thursday wasn't really so much of a
going out night back in the day when we
were younger Friday Saturday Sunday good
times together so the week would be
building up in an almost like you know
oh my God I can't wait for Friday can't
wait for Saturday can't wait and then
Sunday you sort of come down and watch
Top Gear so there was dating apps back
in back in the day uh and even like
Myspace when we were really young was
almost like a dating app because you
could still chat to people on there or
whatever right but now there's like uh
there's that dating app I don't know if
you've heard of it called Thursday
where basically they do events right on
a Thursday and everyone who's single
kind of just goes and meets people
that's weird it is weird but also kind
of clever because the the app kind of
only works on a Thursday and you can
match with people on a Thursday and you
kind of forced into movie Thursday
moving a bit faster than just being like
that smart that's the some people are
quite gameplay I tend to find although
in real life I think that what they're
trying to do is avoid time wasting
essentially because I think there are
some people on dating apps who are just
I don't know just there looking for an
ego boost or whatever and also there's a
bit of indecision or you know they they
because of dating apps there's always
another person you could swipe or
another person you could match with
people get to sort of throw people away
that's a good point actually because I
do think that that's one of the
negatives of dating apps outside of the
convenience is it's the meat market
feeling yeah and I think it's having a
knock-on effect in relationships as well
because in our parents era for example
if someone met someone who they liked it
didn't feel like they had a million
options because social media wasn't a
thing so you'd a want to put more time
and energy into that relationship you
wouldn't give up on it too easily and if
you did consider leaving would be a very
serious decision divorce shame shame on
you and your family yeah and it would
all it would also feel like going to
find someone new would be very difficult
so because you used Goods well it would
it would just change it would be it
would be a different Outlook of it in
terms of how am I going to find someone
new where am I going to meet them
internet dating I think has caused
people to treat men and women but all
treating each other like well there's
another one out the box whenever I need
it so if you want exactly how I want you
to be then why should I come compromise
why should I make any
um you know concessions for things that
may be aren't perfect about you when I'm
convinced because of the Limitless
amount of options that are in the Box
I will find someone who is perfect well
then maybe you're not the one if if
that's the problem no one is perfect but
it is delusional but I don't want to go
out with the delusion
illusions that it's making a society of
delusional people in my opinion who
don't get me wrong there are some people
who are using internet dating I'm sure
and have found the right person who and
they have made those concessions they've
got no you're not perfect but you're
great for me and I'm happy yeah success
story however I think we're we're seeing
a
a culture being brought in where people
are ghosting people are rude people are
just very forward and whatever else and
they're not playing the dating game
anymore it's it's very much like a I
want everything and I want it now kind
of attractive yeah and it's like it's
like it's like Uber Eats Meats dating
it's everyone expecting everything
immediate now easy no hard work no build
up and no concessions it's it's like
you're either perfect or and because of
that there are going to be some people
who are in the wrong frame of mind
because of the system that they're
playing in
and I guess by
they'll wake up when it's too late and
be like [__] I've had all these dates
with all these good people and I
probably didn't have wasted I didn't
give it what I should have give it right
because I was kept saying no not perfect
not perfect not perfect and then I'm
down the road here with someone who my
options are now more limited because I'm
getting older I'm getting uglier and now
I'm like uh
actually I should have settled for that
chick [__] back then when I was
[__] 28 or whatever but I still got a
number no she's now matched with Gary
yeah exactly [__]
Gary what a name
um real name Gareth so in a way it's
great that people can meet that many
people but the negative impact is that I
don't know if it's breeding quality
relationships and a good attitude
towards dating I get that I I think the
other side is some people are just meant
to be single forever well like you know
um I know a lot of people did sort of
pair up and you know there were people
who just weren't really meant to be
together before dating apps but now if
you make it almost too convenient it's
like convenient for people who are just
on the fringes I'd like to make a dating
app what would you call it true
um true love right true love it's good
um but what I mean is I think for people
who want specific things would you like
categorize them yeah just to be able to
[__] well
things like things like
so things that are important to women
and things that are important to men
that they can check off the list to go
like
um cleanliness like I mean yeah
obviously but like
chivalry I think things where women
women care about you know like are you
going to pay for me on the first day and
stuff I'm not I'm not saying all women
do but like certain women have certain
demands certain women want to know your
income they really care about like has
this guy got some cash his [__] together
more more than anything uh men so if
we're breaking down what the two are
looking for generally speaking outside
of General interests and getting along
in terms of making each other laugh
which is unpredictable you can't really
foresee whether that's going to be the
case until you're in a room together
well will I make people laugh when I'm
in a room with them pretty predictable
yeah I mean make millions laughing yeah
Millions uh but generally
relationships are transactional in a
certain sense in terms of and look I
know there's exceptions to the rule and
a lot of women out there are not
specifically with men for money and and
men aren't specifically with women for
their looks but as a species
men's finances do have an impact on
their ability to date in terms of
certain looks sure and and women's looks
have an impact on their ability to get a
man who is able to provide that and has
some status yes
what we find if if we look is that the
more money a guy makes the hot Other
Woman he's usually with that is not a
[__] coincidence here I'm not a
millionaire bro if you know Maya jama's
fella wasn't a basketball player
Uber driver would he be with mayajama
obviously not I mean
no no she's Rich too but but what it
does mean is that women find men with
status more attractive than men without
stairs that is just part of the game I
understand that I think then there's
also little nuances and idiosyncrasies
of that you can't really ever really
tick off in a dating app I feel like the
dating app that's what I'm saying so
what what I think is you should be able
to answer questions that are almost
um not public but that the system
collates the data so for example a
really important one for men is how many
how many dates are we gonna have to go
on before you're quite crude but no but
but I'm not putting this public I'm
saying no no what I mean by that is it
still quite a crude like you know when
you're dating someone if you're like
it's okay so if a man answers the
question after three dates I'm looking
to Shag right is that on the fourth or
on the third just to be absolutely clear
I guess after the third just uh just for
this purpose the night of the third the
Knight of the third I think that that's
quite normal that definitely judging
from what a lot of people say I think
that seems to be like a maybe a
reasonable expectation uh if you to
revive in sexually if you're not vibing
sexually leave another few dates
or one of you is ugly but but there's
also attraction wise there's a there's a
lot of
posturing there's a lot of playing in
the game but realistically I believe
that most women if they have a 15-minute
conversation with you and you don't say
anything dumb and you you seem like a
nice guy and you look like they're cup
of tea they probably know all right if
this keeps going I know I will [__] them
you know what I mean because wow
attraction usually takes seconds to work
out yeah that's what I was kind of
thinking but so the attraction element
isn't I feel like that's a bit easier on
a dating app what I mean is the stuff
which is about the Nuance of a
relationship and the Nuance of the
hierarchy of society all those kind of
things really a dating app should almost
be like listen you want to meet or not
and that's as far as the dating app
should go for me like I don't think it
really needs to go much further I think
the sooner you can get in a room with
someone providing they're not a murderer
or a rate or a phone call yeah maybe
maybe for the women out there do a phone
call First yeah just about this guy what
I'm saying is yeah sure like there's a
there's maybe a bit of a longer process
and maybe there is a bit but this is why
I'm saying what I mean is the sooner you
meet but that's the sooner you can go
yes
where you can get more specific
preferences I call it call me maybe
because the more broad it is the worse
it is the worse it is because you're
getting a lot of people who may not uh
fit within your preference exactly so
you we need to make this more specific
like what are your
um
and this is going to sound mental but
like I think it could work all right
I'll go with you for women it could be
like penis size I want it to be within
these ranges okay what do you think what
do you think for men
okay I want to be in this ring right so
what do you think the average penis size
a woman is looking for in the modern day
is well above average probably do you
think most women you think most women
want an above average size penis would
you think they just want to think it's
an above average size penis when
actually it's probably about average or
below statistically I don't know right
it's most men's penises are
statistically smaller than the average
penis well does that not mean not
average them but what I mean by that
when I go average penis that's what I
mean like what most people think is the
average oh okay okay yeah okay well
whatever but the point is is I think I
don't think many women know what four
inches the difference between four
inches and seven but the point is you
have to measure it like if you put a
phone out like that I reckon most people
go have you got they go uh iPhone Pro
Max they go right do you want the dick
to be bigger or smaller than this well
that might be a way of doing it probably
I mean the woman go is it bigger than
the bread it's the
end the bread bin
oh
well you can't tell that joke anymore
can you sure she's nice yeah they won't
be able to play
um Christmas games so yeah um so sorry
penis size breast size what do you think
most people are looking for breast wise
are we talking Double D
C cup I think Double D's C cup I think
is reasonable men like a [__] set of
dues on them Throw Some D's on it yes
Kanye West that was an old one that
um do you okay so men want boobs women
want a big dick well no but I'm just
saying you can choose your preferences
right so any person will want small
boobs because I've met men who like
small boobs right but a bigger I was
like wow you exist yeah some men like
bigger bums
you should be able to be like the thick
behind if no but not just that like
um chubby little thighs yeah yeah you
could you could pick almost and then you
Whittle it right down and then you get
onto the really important thing
personality exactly right so you know
you want big tits fat thighs good
personality well for me uh boobs are
lovely don't get me wrong and I am a big
fan but it's it's the bum that is the
main thing right I'm more of a person
like the older I've gotten the less I
care about that stuff but the point I'm
making is that no but the point I'm
making is is that the more you can
figure out what you are looking for
whether that be in terms of Personality
we do a personality test as well so
we'll figure out what their interests
are they can tick off those sort of
things we make it really I don't know if
this is what match.com did I don't know
that's my point
we're wasting people's time what you
need to do is go listen do you want to
meet this person or not no but but the
point is is there's certain things about
them like
maybe we could tick off like was your
dad nice to you you know what I mean do
you have Daddy Issues basically well
that was well that seems to be a huge
issue in modern society yeah yeah a lot
of I've I've dealt with a fair bit of
Rage in my life from uh people who don't
have good relationships with their
fathers father these are absolutely and
don't get me wrong all the empathy in
the world but I'm not a psychiatrist do
you know what I'm saying you just
shouldn't have to be yeah yeah you
shouldn't have to you shouldn't have to
but you know and and in many ways you're
probably going to attract women who have
daddy issues because you are a bigger I
mean let's be honest if it wasn't for
deadbeat dads I'd probably be a virgin
so I do have a lot to uh yeah shout out
to the deadbeats out there do you know
what I mean yeah um but equally
be better have a healthy relationship
with your daughters
um I guess what you're saying I think I
think the more we can get
yeah I think like for example we could
do a personality test to to work out how
nice someone is but here's my first
niceness it should be a given but it is
agreeability is probably one as well
reasonable reasonability that something
is a good one what I'm trying to work
out is are you going to be a [__]
lunatic is this person logical or yeah
it should be like a psycho test
basically basically yeah right yeah I
think that's smart because I actually
don't think I want to know I think do
your Show often because if you do we
can't be friends right okay right what
it can be friends I want to be friends
with someone who's screaming all the
time all right okay yeah
but maybe in the bedroom
I mean that's fine okay so what I mean
by that is you work out if they're a
psycho but then in a in a bar things
like how often would you have sex in a
relationship right questions that are
going to be important too doesn't that
change week to week like sometimes
people
it's a rough answer so the men who are
looking at you've got an idea of okay
this is what I'm going to be getting but
what if her sexual appetite increases
when she sees a mansion everyone wants
to hide everything and be like no but
like people people
I think especially women feel like I
don't want to give all that information
over until he's taking me out and spent
some money on me and prove that he
respects me but we're we're just wasting
everyone's [__] time what we're doing
we're getting a guy to Shell out money
for three [__] dates and ultimately
on the third day when he realizes you're
a [__] anyway and he's wasted the money
he's wasted your time you could have
been on dates with somebody who thinks
you're great he's a [__] maybe I don't
know but the point I mean there's a lot
of time wasting going on right no time
locked down to the nitty-gritty everyone
says they hate small talk but let's cut
the [__] [__] then but small Talk's
important it isn't though no but it is
it sort of builds up the moment and you
know small talk is very often what
you're doing during small talk is you're
you will have small jobs
I'm just saying can we just figure out
if we're compatible right I think one of
them should be the question should be
it's not even really a question it's
just more of a oh the Queen's dead
and that you can gauge because this is
the kind of conversation I've had a lot
this week when the queen first died I
met one of my neighbors in the lift I
was in a great mood
and I was on my way home I was on
wasting my family and my kids very down
in the lift with me sort of cast quite a
shadow oh so you're buzzing to see the
bands I'm buzzing to see the kids and I
hold the door open for her because I
know she lives on the uh floor near us
and when we're in the lift she goes
[Music]
sad about the queen isn't it and I was
like yeah you know
um
and when she went no and I'm not joking
that she goes
she would choose the first rainy day of
the year to go wouldn't she
[Music]
kind of went I know it's not the first
rainy day of the year she went a gray
day it's like she knew almost and I was
like
she's in Scotland motion no yeah I would
like you know what I would have said I
would have played along and I would have
been like just her isn't it yeah no but
I did if I know the queen and neither of
us [__] do yeah this is so her yeah
this is such such a Queeny thing so her
to die on a rainy day globally yeah and
and so what should be [__] morons
absolute [__] morons coming out with
a [__] what I really love is you should
have put her in a room with graham soon
I said well I'd write good ball in a
whinge over it what I really enjoy over
the last week is the people who go of
course there have been some
indiscretions within the family but
who doesn't have that you know yeah who
hasn't got an uncle who touches kids or
his own daughter's ass yeah yeah that
was a weird clip wasn't it a bit name
Ari you know when he goes down and it's
sort of his hand lingers I can't really
say that I quite like them well you can
say it cool guys yeah I mean Neymar
seems cool but Neymar
um yeah but this is his mother I mean I
kind of feel like it's more appropriate
to touch your mother's body than it is
your child
stop makes sense
in a way but again I stay away from the
ass whatever happens you know what I
mean yeah yeah whatever happens don't
don't yeah these are so these are the
two questions yeah the queen do you
touch any of your family's bottoms on
the dating site yeah after you've gotten
through those do you want to meet this
guy or not listen if you're not a psycho
when you walk up to someone in a bar you
don't go interests and they go
um I like movies and uh long walks in
the park and you go no like you have to
sometimes you meant not to share every
interest with a person sometimes you're
meant to be become more compatible I
just reach the gaps between I think
dating apps make it too hard dating apps
make it too easy to [__] though and
that's part of the problem as well is
because men are out there like ravenous
[__] zombies right and unfortunately
like Epstein in a crash I feel like
women
all changing in society because
of what they're kind of going through in
a romantic sense like
dating apps or killing romance and and
because of that women are becoming
really jaded and fed up I feel like with
with men out there there's very little
romance in the book right now yeah you
know the the the The Accidental bumping
of the shoulder on the tube and the guy
turns around and gives number and you
know it's all done that does not happen
anymore do you know what I mean yeah
okay people look at each other in public
and go yeah I would definitely match
with her on a dating app but I can't
talk to her in public so therefore
I'm not doing anything right right so so
the point is I think this Jade attitude
is turning women more masculine and men
more than like when the gender rules are
are not really there as much anymore
we're becoming a bit closer I think
women are becoming fed up as well so
yeah like Fed Up of men not being
grown-ups basically I I kind of feel
like that's happening from conversations
that we've had with people in the last
year it's sort of coming across that way
I mean I could be I could I'm not the
best guy to judge this but I could be
wrong but but I just feel like there's a
we're all Fed Up kind of vibe going yeah
but and I do think that comes down to
maybe a lack of maturity there is that
Meme that I quite like where it's like
my parents at 23 and they're like buying
a house and they're like basically look
like they're 50 and then me at 23 and
it's like just someone sitting in their
pants on an Xbox or whatever I mean
that's partly down to the yeah the
economy um but is that not also the
infantilization of people like maybe
there could be a bit more of like you
know
these apps do make you a bit it kind of
makes it a bit too lightweight it's not
nothing really feels very real you don't
have anything if we had a realer world
you don't have to be accountable for the
words that you're writing on a screen
either and as we've seen with the
YouTube comments and like people get
very brave and feel very uh you know Big
Boy when in reality you would not speak
like that to someone and I think the
same probably applies to dating apps
where women are probably hearing things
more more so women than men obviously
women can be [__] as well
um as men can be [__]
um but you know um
but um
I mean Prince Charles was writing this
[__] back in the 70s and there was no
dating app back then so clearly this was
always a thing but what I mean is is
Prince Charles had developed the
relationship with a woman where he knew
that there was consent there and that
she was more than happy to hear his
weird [__] whereas women know you could
be one message in and boom can I be a
tampon you know right and there's a knob
in the chat or whatever you don't send a
dick pic
see what I'm saying so yeah
um try and be more of a gentleman I just
think
it goes a long way like you don't get me
wrong like uh uh you'd have to be
perfect or anything but I just think
women would appreciate it do you think
though it also it casts the neck quite
wide so a man who sends a dick pic to
100 women
he's not looking for the women who are
repulsed he's looking for the one woman
in the hundred that goes that's my sort
of thing
so but you know what I mean it's quite a
quick way I think of getting rid of
people people who do that they get off
on the fact that the women are just
looking up yeah yeah why do you think
that is that's a bit weird as well it's
the same reason some men wear a raincoat
and one flash people in parks and [__]
like that yeah same but it's it's like a
it's like a safer version of that for
them do you know when when
um I think when my mum was younger they
had
um they had in the local area a Peeping
Tom do you know what a Peeping Thomas
yeah I think my aunt had one of those
right these guys would like stare
through the window at her yeah she was
getting changed yeah yeah so obviously
she has a sister as well so the two
young women in the house and they used
to see a man outside in the bushes
and uh the police caught him in the end
but I thought do those people exist
anymore you know because of the internet
those people like do they just go on the
internet now basically yeah is that
still then perverted if they go on the
internet like do you think this is
another thing that you've just brought
up in my head I don't know if they do
this but they should verify
um before like so when we signed the
betting apps we have to verify who we
are yeah you have to send a affordable
ID to prove that you're of legal age
yeah yeah sometimes getting on a betting
up these days like [__] hacking into
NASA yeah right the point is is what I'm
finding out there dating apps for
security for especially for women
obviously but men as well
we that all should be verified so that
everyone you're talking to is the real
person there is no fakes out there and
you know who they are because people
have been killed on Tinder and [__]
like that we've seen the [__] tender
swindler and all of that like there
needs to be like proof of that and I
can't believe that they're not I don't
think they're doing that you know what I
mean that that should be like a minimum
yeah or at least they've not been doing
it I don't obviously we don't really
know but I guess there is that like that
level of um people probably on a dating
app and they have to verify something
but really the app almost relies on you
dating someone to verify it's you do you
know what I mean
it's such an easy thing isn't it to sort
of so there's a lot a lot of
infrastructure in our dating up that we
can make there's a lot there that's
we've just brainstormed people can go
off and make it now if they want I guess
but I would like a cup let us know um
some topics for the next chat we're
gonna do we are going to try and do more
of these podcasts uh uh just what do you
lot want us to talk about I've
thoroughly enjoyed your input for the
day because thank you you're now
collaborators the committee uh podcast
who guides us who guides us we've got
plenty of other subjects to discuss So
yeah thank you for your input and uh God
Save the Queen the fascist regime